Cromwell: Hi.
How you guys doing?
So, um,
it's been a busy day, huh?
How 'bout that keynote?
It was awesome, right?
So my name's Ray Cromwell.
And what I want
to show you today
is two things.
One is if you're
a GWT programmer,
an existing GWT programmer,
and you've done apps before,
I'd like to try
to show you a new way
of doing GWT applications
that you may not
have thought of before.
And if you're not
a GWT programmer,
maybe you're just
a programmer using
LAMP Frameworks
and hand-coded JavaScript,
I'd like to show you
an interesting way
to use GWT that might,
you know, influence you
to try it out.
So...
First before I begin,
let's kind of discuss
where web applications
have come and gone.
Let's look at the history.
So Web 1.0 basically was about
server-side round-trips.
So you designed
a Web 1.0 application,
every time
someone clicked on anything,
it did an HTTP request,
it went to the server.
The server processed
some UI state,
maybe did some logic
on the back-end,
and then it re-rendered
the whole page,
shipped down a big, massive
HTML and CSS and images.
And that worked pretty well,
but the problem is
is that it has
a lot of latency in there.
So the experience is not--
it's not that great.
And then what people
started doing
is they started writing,
once JavaScript kinda became
powerful and faster
and people started
to take it serious
as, like, a real language
and not just something
to validate forms or something,
is they started writing
large applications,
you know, like Gmail,
like Google Docs--
these large,
monolithic applications
that sort of mimic
the desktop experience.
And one of the features
of these applications
is they really don't
ship any HTML down
to the application after
it's been initially loaded.
So you load up the HTML,
maybe it sets up a structure,
you download a very large
amount of JavaScript,
and then everything else
is done with REST requests
all on the back-end.
And the JavaScript modifies
the DOM
from that point forward.
However, that model
is not for everyone.
That model works
really well for an application
like Wave, which is
an incredible application
where it really needs
to do that.
But a lot of the applications
that people have built,
like in the Enterprise
and for The Web
are built on the model of,
you know, page reloads.
And that's great.
So what people
are doing these days
is they are going back
to their Web 1.0 applications
and they're adding
a little bit of JavaScript
here and there
and gradually making it
more "Web 2.0ey,"
if I can use that word,
by eliminating page reloads
and using AJAX REST request
on the back-end.
And that's sort of like
the predominant model you see
nowadays in a lot of start-ups.
There's also kind of been
a return to simplicity.
So if you remember
what happened
during the dot-com era,
is, you know,
Java got really popular,
and people started building
these monolithic frameworks,
and they just got
bigger and bigger and bigger.
And it kinda
culminated in J2EE
where, you know, to write
something really simple
like a Hello World,
you had to write, you know,
like 10,000 lines of code
of boilerplate.
And people kind of
rebelled to that.
And the first rebellion
was to sort of pull back,
and you got things
like Spring where people said,
"I only want IoC containers,"
or, "I only want
dependency injection.
I don't really need
all this extra stuff."
You got, like,
Spring and Hibernate,
and that worked really well.
And then it's been
kind of simplified further
because a lot of times
people don't even need that,
so you see
with Rails and Django
this active record pattern
where people just generate
a skeleton app,
and it's very simple,
like objects are directly mapped
to the database
and they spit out HTML
from PHP, Python, or Rails.
And it's very, very simple.
Your code base is small.
You can get it up and running
in, like, five minutes.
And usually what they do when
people do these applications
is they first sort of
get it working with HTML
without JavaScript.
So, like, your application
would work
even if JavaScript's disabled.
And then they go back,
and they sort of add
on top of it HTML
to make it more
client-side interactive.
So the page reloads
are gradually replaced.
So essentially
the key thing is, is that
logic from a server
that used to deal with UI
is gradually pushed
the the client.
And the way people
do this is they use
popular JavaScript libraries
to sort of walk them
through it,
like jQuery, Dojo,
Prototype, MooTools,
there's, like, a bunch of them,
and they're all great.
My perspective,
which, you know,
is not necessarily
the right one,
but as a GWT developer,
I don't like the fact that
the end-to-end tool chain
is not coherent for me.
Like in other words,
if I'm doing Rails or Python
on the back-end,
I have a different
set of tools--
I'm using Rake
or something else
to basically build
and configure my app.
And then when I get
on the client side,
it's different.
How I unit test
is different.
How I check the app
for errors
or inspect it
when inspection--
It's all different.
And I kind of prefer
to have an end-to-end solution
that works on both sides
using the tools
that I'm used to.
So basically what I've done
is I've built a library
that allows you to do
what people do
with libraries like jQuery
and Dojo and Prototype,
but I've done it with GWT.
And if you are not familiar
with GWT,
and I hope you are
familiar with it,
basically, to me,
it's a really kick-butt,
optimizing complier
and hosted mode browser tool.
And it produces
incredibly fast code.
I mean, I'll show you
something later
about some of the code
it generates,
and sometimes
it even amazes me.
It reduces start-up
latency a lot.
It produces
very small code.
Most of the time,
you can reduce
all the HTTP requests
in your app down to just two,
and sometimes just one.
It integrates with all
of the Java language tools
that you're used to--
your IDEs, IntelliJ, Eclipse,
Maven, Ant--
for build tools,
your continuous
integration tools--
JUnit testing,
checkstyle, FindBugs--
all the tools you're used to
with Java that are mature,
they've been around
for ten years.
They just work,
and now they work
with your client-side code.
However, if you're
in this room today
and you're not
a GWT programmer,
it may be a big leap for you.
I'll be honest,
there is a learning curve.
If you're, like,
a JavaScript programmer
or you're doing Rail--
you know, you started
with Python or Ruby,
it's a pretty big leap.
And also,
rightly or wrongly,
the way GWT
is currently constructed,
the library, it sort of
encourages people
to make these desktop
metaphor applications
using Widget abstraction.
So it kind of encourages you
to build something
that you would build
with, like, Swing.
It encourages
monolithic applications
that don't have
more than one page,
and there are times
to do that.
That's actually
a perfectly valid reason
as we saw with Wave
and with Gmail and Google Docs.
But there's a lot of other
applications people do
where multipages
are a good thing.
And the other problem is,
is that the learning curve
for UI designers
who are gonna
make your site look good
would be pretty big
for them to start writing
all of their code
using GWT Widget abstractions.
They want to deal
with HTML and CSS
because that's what they know.
So it could conflict with
your existing design process
in your company.
So let's talk about
progressive enhancement.
So it's different
in every company,
but in some of the companies
I've worked in
the way the website
starts out, you know,
besides defining
what the requirements
and new cases are,
is that a designer
will sit down with, like,
Photoshop or some other tool
and he'll mock up
what the UI will look like.
Sometimes it's like an image
or some other tool.
And, you know,
he'll show it to everyone.
Everyone will sign off on it,
say, "Hey, this looks great.
"I like the way
this looks now.
We want to make it
into a website."
And then they'll hand it to
some guys who know how to code.
Sometimes the designer
and the coder are the same
if they're lucky.
I'm not one of those people.
I'm really bad at UI design.
They'll hand it to a coder,
and he'll take that design
from Photoshop
and he'll slice it up,
and he'll reify it
into, like, HTML and CSS,
and he'll make
the code generate
what the designer
had in mind,
typically using, like,
PHP or Python, or Rails
and things like that.
And you'll end up with
a working Web 1.0 application.
You know,
you click on something
and it goes to the server,
and it runs
another PHP script,
which outputs, you know,
the website,
again with all the template
and nice UI design stuff on it.
And then after that,
the guys will say,
"Hey, you know, let's start
trying to make this site
"more dynamic.
"Like, you know, maybe
when I'm paging through,
"like, an Enterprise report,
"rather than reloading
the page every time,
"I'll just launch off
a REST request to the server
"on the back-end,
get the data,
"and then I'll just
repopulate the DOM
without leaving the page."
So they start to enhance
the existing UI
by layering JavaScript
on top of it.
But the cool thing is,
is that if somebody
comes to the page
and they don't have
JavaScript turned on,
the app will still work.
And there are places
where people do that.
I believe in Japan
a lot of the mobile phones
actually don't have
JavaScript.
They just have HTML support.
And also, it facilitates SCO--
search engine optimization
and accessibility.
So I mean, the search engine
sees your app.
If it doesn't understand
JavaScript,
it still sees
the HTML content,
so it can index it
and find it.
So here's an example
of how someone
would progressively
enhance something.
This is sort of--
would represent the output
of an RSS feed reader.
So you've got, like,
a container element.
And you've got a div
with class = article.
So you've got two articles.
And then you've got, like,
a h3 element with a Title,
a p tag with classical
summary,
which is a summary
of the article.
And then, like,
another p tag
which is the entire body
of the article,
which would be quite large.
And then a bulleted list
of ul li,
which is the possible actions
you could take.
Like maybe you're gonna
leave a comment,
or maybe you're gonna
do a Trackback.
And what you want to do
is you maybe want
to enhance this a little bit.
And maybe, like,
you don't want to show
all of the body material
expanded right away.
You wanted
to have it collapsed.
And then, like, maybe
when you click on something,
it expands it to read it.
So here's how you would do it
in jQuery.
So someone would write
this little snippet of code.
They'd say find the body
that contains all the content
using the CSS selector
.article.body.
So find me the div--
Find something that has
the class = article,
find something that has
the class = the body,
and call hide.
Now what hide does is it sets
display colon none.
So it basically
hides the element
so you can't see it
anymore.
Then the next thing
they might do
is they will say,
"I'm gonna add
a new action to that list
of where it says
comment and trackback,"
which is like
read the article or expand it
so now you can see it.
So they say
find the container tag
then find the article element,
and then find ul element.
And I'm gonna prepend an li
as the first child
of that ul.
And it says,
"Read the article"
or "Read Body,"
so it's a link.
See the A link up there.
Now they have to add something
to handle that link.
So what they do
is then they write
another bit of code
which targets that A link
that they just injected.
And that says,
"Okay, find any action
"with an li element
that's called Read Body
that has an A link in it
and add a click handler to it."
And what the click handler does,
if you can see it there,
is it says, "Okay,
find the parent ul element
"of this li,
"find the previous sibling,
which is the body tag,
"it's a sibling
of the ul tag--
"it's kind of walking
out the DOM--
and then toggle it."
So that's gonna
make it be shown.
So I'm gonna show you
a quick example
of what that would look like.
This is actually
from the jQuery tutorial.
Okay.
And I'm gonna scroll down.
Well, we may have to resize
a little bit here.
Okay.
So I'm gonna scroll down here.
And here's what
it would look like.
So here's it in a browser.
And after you execute
that jQuery code,
I click that Read Body
and it expands the content.
So that's what we want to do.
We've, you know, progressively
enhanced the page
to make it just a little bit
easier to use.
So before I go on,
let me discuss the core
jQuery concepts as I see them.
This may not be how
other people see them,
but this is kind of
what I infer from it.
Number one is querying.
So instead of using DOM methods
to navigate the DOM,
like get elements
by tag name--
you know, get child node
or get first child
or get next sibling and so on,
which is really painful--
you write a CSS
selector query.
The library executes it,
finds all the elements
that match it,
and then basically
then you perform
a bunch of operations
on it.
And the way you perform
those operations
is by chaining method calls.
So you could say,
"Okay, find me
all the div tags
"that have class = foo,
"and then set its background
color to be red,
"and add this event handler,
and, you know, change this
attribute of the thing."
And you can do multiple
operations by chaining.
It also provides a pretty
powerful set of functions
to manipulate the DOM,
to inject content,
to remove content,
to wrap content.
So it just moves stuff around,
and they're really powerful.
Much more powerful
than what you get
in the basic DOM Level 2
interface.
It provides a facility
for attaching arbitrary data
to any element,
and also attaching binding
event handlers to elements.
And finally,
probably the biggest thing
to jQuery's success
is that it has
a really, really simple way
to write plugins for it.
So people,
after they write things,
like thing you just saw
where it kind of modifies
that feed reader output
to make it collapsible,
they would change that
into a plugin
and maybe call it
the feed collapse plugin.
And then they'd publish it
somewhere,
and people
could just include it.
And then with one line of code,
they could just apply it
to their feed.
So it has a really nice way
of doing plugins.
So what's GQuery?
GQuery is a jQuery clone
written in GWT.
So it's written in Java code.
It's compiled to JavaScript.
But it's designed to fit
in the sort of workflow
that people who do
progressive enhancement
on Web 1.0 applications
are used to.
And I tried to make it
easy to learn for people
who have used jQuery.
So the syntax, you know,
maybe surprisingly
doesn't look like Java.
It actually looks
like JavaScript,
but you're actually
in Java code.
However,
you do get a benefit.
It's that underneath
all of that code
that kind of looks like
it's not even Java code,
it's actually being
type checked.
You get code sensibility,
pop-ups, Javadoc pop-ups,
and all the other benefits
of GWT, which I'll show you.
So here's an example.
This is legal Java code.
Sometimes people are kind of
surprised when they see this
because you usually don't
name a function $.
But yes, there is a function
called $ in my library,
and it's statically exported,
so you can import it
at a top level,
and you just refer to it
as $.
So what this code would do
is it would find all
of the div.menu items
in the current page
that this is running
and set their vertical align
property to top.
Now what's interesting about
this is that I'm not doing
"vertical-align","top"
like you would do
in jQuery.
In actuality,
what these are
is these are typesafe enums.
And the interesting thing
about this is,
is that the IDE
will make it impossible
for you to type
a combination
of CSS property name
and value
that are invalid
according to the CSS Spec.
It will do it at edit time,
and it will also check it
at compile time.
But more than that,
it can also show you a pop-up
of what the legal values are
and even Javadoc taken from
the CSS2 Spec
or from
the Quirksmode database.
So as an example,
I'll bring up my IDE
just to show you
what this experience is like.
So let's say I want to set
a CSS property on this.
I'll type in CSS,
and then I'll hit
my completion.
And you can see
vertical align is one of them.
Think I've got to double.
That'll do it.
Let me try this background--
Did I not--
Maybe I didn't import
something right.
Okay, yeah, that's why
it's not seeing it.
Oops.
My IDE gets too smart
sometimes.
Okay, now it should work.
So there you go,
background color,
display, width.
You might say, "Okay,
if I put the display property,
what are the possible values?"
Oops.
Block, inline, inline block,
and so on.
And in fact,
you can even hit Javadoc
and I can see
from the CSS2 Spec,
like, what each one
of these will do.
Because you might not use
the run in
or in the inline block
display property very much.
You might not remember
what it's like.
And, you know,
this is nothing--
I haven't done anything
to me IDE.
There's no plugin
to my IDE.
Any IDE will show this
because it's just a fact--
a property
of the Java code.
It's just Javadoc.
So another example
is, like, for example
this vertical align property
takes not just top
or bottom or baseline
and those kind of things.
It actually
can take a value.
So I can say--
I can go here and say--
Well, okay, I can put in middle,
baseline, stuff like that.
But I can also
put in a length,
like ten centimeters.
So what happens
is the IDE knows that
the vertical align property
can take one of these
enumerated values
or it can take centimeters
or some other length value.
But it can't, for instance,
take a color.
So if I put--
if I put something like this...
RBG, you know, like,
blah, blah, blah.
It's an error.
You see it's red.
So it knows that vertical align
does not take colors.
So it basically makes it harder
to make a mistake.
Oops, okay, so let's go back
to the presentation.
So there's other benefits
to using types,
and this is where the GWT
compiler comes in.
The compiler has
various optimizations,
and one of it's called
type tightening.
And the compiler
can actually see, like,
what values are being used
sometimes
and whether or not
there's any other alternative.
So the compiler can infer
in this case
that I only use
the top property,
and I only use the vertical
align property name.
So what it did
is when I compiled it,
it eliminated
the CSS routine.
And it eliminated
all the other properties
that you might set,
and it just inlined this loop,
which is for i = 0 to
I list the number of elements
that have been matched,
set this
element.style property,
vertical align = top.
So basically it removed
everything else from the program
except for that
and inlined it.
You can't write
faster code than that,
even by hand.
There will be no JavaScript
code you can write
that'll execute
faster than that.
So this is another
quick example.
Can anybody
see anything wrong
with these lines
of jQuery code?
There's some subtle
errors in here.
So the first one might be
a little bit obvious
if you're looking at it.
"Background color"
is spelled wrong.
So if you actually
wrote this code
and you execute it
in your browser,
you won't get an error.
I think in Firefox if you look
in the error console,
you might see it.
But in many browsers, you won't
actually get any error at all.
And if it's something obscure,
like some background color
or some really tiny element
somewhere,
you might not ever
even see it.
You might deploy it
to production,
and you'll never know
unless somebody, like,
later on, a week later, says,
"Hey, this color
didn't get set properly."
Second line, lavender's
not a system color.
So there's a whole bunch
of CSS2 system colors,
like, you know,
magenta and cyan and stuff.
Lavender's not one of them.
The next one
is kind of interesting.
Maybe you're running
a CSS selector
with an ID selector,
and that element might not
exist in the page
you're targeting.
It'd be interesting to get
a warning when that happened--
like you wrote a CSS selector
and it doesn't match anything.
The next one's kinda tricky.
Can anybody guess
what's wrong with that one?
Yeah, so it's binding
a callback event handler
for the double click event.
The problem is
it's called "dblclick"
not "doubleclick."
So I think that, you know,
could be an easy mistake
to make by some people.
The last one I'm gonna leave
for an exercise to the reader.
So later on, you can go and,
you know,
download the presentation,
see if you can figure out
that last one.
Okay, so like I said earlier,
because it's Java,
you get to use all of your
normal JavaScript tools--
sorry Java tools--
so you can do JUnit tests
using your IDE.
Here's an example of me
running that div.menu
and setting the vertical align
top property.
And then I have
a little loop there
where I loop over
the same selector
and assert that
the actual elements
had their top properties--
the vertical align property
set at the top.
And then of course you see
a little pop-up there
for my IDE.
I can just run that
right in my IDE
and check it
right then and there,
or I could run it
at build time.
There's some other cool stuff
you can do with jQuery
and unit testing.
If I have time,
I'll talk about it later.
So now I'm gonna show you
a quick demo
of a progressive enhancement.
Here is--
So here is some HTML
that's basically
just two div tags
with some bulleted
lis in them,
and that's all.
And what I've done
is I've written a little bit
of Java code in GQuery.
And I've turned it into
sort of like
a PowerPoint-like slide.
I transitioned
to another slide there.
So if you don't have
JavaScript enabled,
you'll still see
the information,
but if you come
with JavaScript enabled,
you'll get something
kind of looks
sort of like
a PowerPoint presentation.
So the cool thing
about that is,
is that if I go to
that website.
This is deployed
on App Engine.
And if I open up Firebug,
you'll see this.
Okay, here's the generated
JavaScript.
So its compiled
and it's obfuscated.
You couldn't read this
and figure out, like,
what it's doing.
So you might need
to debug this.
Now, this is deployed
to production.
So, you know, this could be,
like, an app
that people are using.
It's been in production.
It's been reliable for a while.
And you might need
to check on some bug
that you suspect
is somewhere.
Well, GWT has this thing
called hosted mode.
And what you can do is
I can attach
a Java debugger
to that HTML site.
So I'm gonna click
the debug button up here,
and I'm gonna launch
hosted mode.
And it's gonna take a second.
You can see it's connecting
to gwt.query.appspot.com/demo.
So I'm loading up
HTML and JavaScript here.
And there it is.
You just saw it.
But I've got
a break point set
in my Java debugger
to when I click on something.
So I'm gonna click
the mouse button.
And you can see
that my break point triggered
inside my Java IDE
but from a production compiled
and deployed JavaScript site.
And I think
that's pretty cool,
because I can step
through this
and try to figure out
where the bug is,
and I don't even have
to touch the production.
I don't have to do anything
to get a debug build.
I don't have to put a debug
build on a production site--
let's say
un-obfuscated JavaScript
or un-minified JavaScript--
in order to use Firebug
to debug it.
I can debug in the original
source code,
which I think
is really, really powerful.
So let me go back
to the presentation.
So let me just mention
sort of an analogy.
Hosted mode
is really complicated.
I don't even fully understand
how it's implemented,
but by analogy,
I'll compare it to GreaseMonkey.
Is anybody familiar
with GreaseMonkey in Firefox?
Yeah, so GreaseMonkey
kind of allows you
to inject JavaScript
in the page.
You can kind of, like,
when a page loads up,
you can basically
intercept stuff
and inject your own, you know,
modifications to the DOM.
And hosted mode
is like GreaseMonkey,
but instead of injecting
JavaScript,
it injects Java.
It doesn't really inject Java
into the page.
What it does is it kind of
intercepts the attempt
to load that obfuscated,
pre-compiled JavaScript
will callbacks into the VM
where that same code,
in its original Java form,
is being executed
in the JVM as bytecode.
So that's how I was able
to step through it like that.
So it's a really, really
powerful tool.
It allows you to basically
make changes in Java
and hit reload and have them
show up instantly
without even compiling,
'cause that's
a major complaint
a lot of people who use
dynamic languages have.
They're like, "Well, I don't
like a build process," right?
"I got into--you know,
if I'm using, like, Python
"or Ruby
or something like that,
"or I'm using JavaScript,
"I make a modification
and I hit reload,
"and I see the changes
instantly.
"I don't have to, you know,
run Ant or run Maven
"and wait, like, 50 seconds
for it to build
and then deploy the ward and,
you know, do, like, that stuff."
They want
instant turnaround time,
and that's what
hosted mode gives you.
Okay, so let's talk
about performance.
You wouldn't want to use
GQuery if the performance
of running these selectors
was poor.
And--so you might have
concerns about that.
And a lot of people
have had concerns,
because the original selector
implementations were written,
you know, using JavaScript
parsed the CSS selectors
and executing it
in JavaScript.
It turns out
all of the HTML 5 browsers--
in fact including
the non-HTML browsers, like IE8,
have selectors
implemented natively now.
There's a function called
"query selector all."
So you can basically
just ask the browser
to execute the selector.
However, for other browsers,
like on some mobile phones
and IE 6 and older versions
of Firefox and Opera,
you still need to have
an alternative.
So I'm gonna show you
a benchmark.
Now there's this benchmark
that jQuery and MooTools
and Dojo often use
called SlickSpeed.
It's a selector engine
benchmark.
And it's used to, you know,
sort of see how they compare
to each other
but also sort of to improve
their performance every time.
And I sort of modified it
a little bit
and added GQuery to it
as one of the benchmarks,
and I changed
the visualizations.
So rather than just
being a table,
it's a horse race.
So I'll be honest with you
up front,
this is not rigged.
I may not win.
Sometimes it's pretty close
because the selector engines
in these other libraries
are very,
very well-optimized now.
So it's really hard,
and if I do win,
it won't be very--
by much.
However, I hope you guys
are gonna root for me
because I don't want
the GWT team to be angry with me
if I put up
a poor performance.
So let's click Start Race
and see what happens.
Oh, by the way,
down here is a table
of the selectors being run.
That's from the SlickSpeed
benchmark.
So here we go.
And we're off.
So let's see.
It looks like they're running
neck and neck here.
JQuery is--
GQuery's pulling
a little bit ahead,
but they're still
sort of close together.
Looks like Dojo's
catching up a little bit,
at least to me.
It's getting close.
Okay, let's--Come on.
Come on, GQuery.
Come on, come on.
Yes.
Bruce and the GWT team
are not gonna kill me.
Oh, oh, he came back.
Dojo came back at the end.
Whoa, that was--
Phew, that was close.
[applause]
I counted my chickens
before they hatched there.
But if you want to see
how close it actually is,
look at the bottom row,
the total row at the bottom.
9.26 milliseconds
versus jQuery,
which is 10.2 milliseconds.
That's about one millisecond
difference.
So that's very, very close.
And the reason
why it's so close
is because they're delegating
most of their implementation
to the native browser
query selector engine.
And a lot of the performance
improvements we get
probably come down to some stuff
the GWT compiler does.
However, let's go back
to the presentation here.
There is the subject of IE6,
which I refer to
as the dreaded IE6.
From now on, that's what
I'll refer to it to.
And unfortunately,
I don't have, like,
a VM on my Mac here
to basically show you IE,
or maybe fortunately I don't
have any way to run IE6 here.
However, I did take
a screen shot from a PC,
and as you can see,
running the pure
JavaScript selector engine,
the difference
is more substantial.
We win by, you know,
a pretty good margin.
Or if you look
at the bottom line,
about 500 milliseconds
for GQuery
versus Prototype,
3,800 milliseconds.
Or against jQuery,
655 milliseconds,
maybe about
a 40%, 50% improvement.
That's pretty good.
I don't want to toot
GWT's horn too much,
but that's
a pretty good result.
What about size, right?
I mean, how big is the output
of our GQuery library?
You don't want
a really bulky library,
you don't want to download
100 K of Java code
to implement these selectors.
And, you know, it could be--
You know, we're generating
JavaScript from Java,
so maybe it's really bloated.
I mean, you know,
it's not as good
as hand-coded JavaScript where
you can do a lot of tricks.
Here's an example.
This is one line of code
from GQuery.
It's $("div.note")--
Find all the note elements,
the class = note elements
in the page
and replace their inner text
with "Hello Google I/O."
So the GQuery library is about
10,000 lines of Java code.
It's 300 kilobytes
of source on disk.
So what would be
the compiled JavaScript
output?
15 kilobytes or larger maybe.
So the size of jQuery
is about 15 kilobytes on disk.
I think 1.3,
it's a little bit bigger,
like 21 or something.
What would you say
about seven kilobytes,
a 50% reduction?
If I came to you and said,
"Hey, I got this
C++ compiler,
"and it will produce
executables
for you and your customers
that are 50% smaller,"
I mean, would it be something
you'd be interested in buying
or, you know, trying out?
I think that's pretty good.
But it turns out
the actual output
from that compile up there,
760 bytes for Safari.
That's--
[applause]
Thank you.
Thank the GWT team
for that one.
So the interesting thing
is that's the Safari version
where it can delegate
to the native selector engine.
That's a reduction
from 300 kilobytes of source
down to the obfuscated
output of 760 bytes.
So I don't know,
what's the calculation there?
It's like a 300 to 1
reduction in size.
It's pretty amazing.
And even versus
some of the other libraries,
it's pretty substantial.
It's actually smaller
than the [indistinct] headers
used to fetch it.
So if you were
to fetch this code,
it's actually
smaller than that.
Here's, like, another way
to visualize it.
Actually, I didn't get to do
what I wanted
for this presentation.
But if you Uuencoded it
or Base64 encoded it,
it actually fits
on a T-shirt.
[laughter]
I wouldn't want to calculate
how many T-shirts it would take
to put some of the other
libraries on there.
You might have to visit
an outlet store.
So you might be wondering,
like, how it is
that this can be possible.
And I'll try to explain
a little bit
about, like, how it works.
So one of the advantages
we have with GWT
is we have a compile phase.
So we can parse
and run selectors at run time,
like the other libraries do
with JavaScript.
But we can also pre-compile
the selectors at compile time.
So when it's compiling
the Java to JavaScript,
it can also compile
the CSS selectors to JavaScript.
So we can omit
the parsing step
that the other libraries
have to deal with completely.
So that code doesn't make it
into the output.
Also we can inline functions.
So a lot of stuff in JavaScript
impacts performance.
Like, making a call
that's polymorphic,
like upper Prototype chain
actually has performance
implications.
It turns out having, like,
global functions
on the window objects--
global script is pretty fast.
And then on IE6,
there's a bunch of other stuff
that the GWT compiler does
that I don't want to get into,
but it really helps IE6.
But really the core reason
why it's so small and fast
is that only fields and methods
that are referenced
are actually emitted
in the output.
So typically with JavaScript,
you know, you might have
a library and, you know,
have, like, 50 JavaScript
functions in there.
You have no idea
which ones are gonna be called
and which ones won't,
so you just include all of them
in the whole library
and deploy with that.
But what GWT does
is it says,
"Hey, you know what,
"you only use the text function
to replace inner text.
"So I don't need
the special effects framework,
the animation framework,
the click handler stuff."
It just throws
all that stuff out the window,
and it only emits the code
that you actually use.
So like I said,
"G dub T" query or GWT query,
GQuery, has this concept
of compile time selectors.
It can also do
run time selectors.
You can write $
and a query expression,
and it will parse that
at run time.
If you do that,
the GWT compiler will be forced
to include
the run time parses.
It'll say, "Hey, you know,
you're trying to evaluate
"a selector at run time.
"I need to go pull in
all that code
to parse CSS selectors
and evaluate them."
So you might want to do that
when you're first prototyping
the application.
But then later on,
you might want to go,
"Okay, I'm gonna make
my application
smaller to download
and faster."
You go back and you can
re-factor those
into compile time selectors.
And the way you do that
is quite simple.
If you've something like
the GWT image bundle before,
it's kind of similar.
But what you do
is you make an interface.
Here I have
public interface slide.
And I extend another interface
called Selectors.
And then what I do
is for each selector
that I want to run,
I declare a method.
So here I have a method
called allSlideBullets,
another one called
slideBulletCtx,
another one called allSlides.
And then you use
a Java annotation,
@selector, to tell it that,
"Okay, when you call
allSlideBullets,
"I want it to actually
return the result of executing
div.slide li."
Then you hand this off
to the compiler,
and the GQuery library
takes over
and uses a feature of GWT
called Generators,
and it will parse
that div.slide li
at compile time.
It's like a compiler plugin.
And it generate code
that actually implements
that allSlideBullets
function.
So no parsing code actually
makes it into your output.
You might be wondering,
what happens when you call
$(selector)?
Well, there's another
feature of GWT called
Deferred Binding
and Permutations.
This might have been discussed
in some of the other
presentations,
but GWT compiles a separate
version of the output
for each browser--
one for Safari,
one for IE6, for example.
And that means that,
for example,
the Safari users
don't have to download
all this bloated code
to implement selectors
that IE6 needs,
because it has
native acceleration
for query selectors called
querySelectorAll.
So it just leaves those out.
But on Firefox2
and older Safari browsers,
they don't have
querySelectorAll,
but they do have XPath.
They have this function called
document.evaluate.
So for those browsers
what happens is at compile time,
it will parse
the CSS2 selector
and then translate it
into an XPath string,
and then it passes it
to document.evaluate.
So it produces one line of code
to implement the selector.
document.evaluate, quote,
and then some XPath.
That's all it does.
And then for all
the other browsers,
of course like IE6,
it just uses
lots of regular expressions
to parse the selectors
and then emits
a bunch of DOM calls
directly into the output.
Like, you know,
get elements by tag name,
traverse the children,
check to see
if they have the class
that you're trying to match
and so on.
Compile time selectors
do another cool thing,
is they can short-circuit stuff
even with the native
querySelectorAll.
I've benchmarked this
and it turns out, for example,
to getElementById
is still faster
than calling
querySelectorAll,
probably because they don't
have to parse anything.
So for example,
if you use a selector
like # and then the ID
of an element,
the compile time selector
will not emit
querySelectorAll
with, like, the #foo
for example.
Instead, it will delegate
to getElementById.
So it'll just produce,
you know,
getElementById #foo
in the output.
And if you have a browser
that has this function
called
getElementsByClassName,
it will delegate to that.
Otherwise, it will fall back
to the native selector,
'cause getElementsByClassName
seems to be faster
than querySelectorAll too
if you're just doing
a class name lookup.
And on Firefox2
or the XPath-specific browsers,
it basically has
that same short-circuiting.
It will short-circuit
for IDs
and some other
particular queries.
And then even for
the dreaded IE6,
it will generate
inlined calls
by parsing the CSS selector
and generating inlined calls
to DOM method
to get elements by tag name.
So it kind of
unrolls everything.
That's how we get our speed.
And it's possible
to short-circuit or eliminate
some of the cases.
This is the most immature
part of GQuery.
So even though
we're performing
well ahead
of the other libraries,
in fact, believe it or not,
there's a lot of overhead left.
So when I get to the end
of the presentation
and talk about how you can
contribute to the project,
I'm accepting patches,
'cause there's a lot of stuff
we can do to speed it up
even more than it already is.
Okay, let me show you
a real app.
This is the Partuza
OpenSocial Container.
It's an Apache Shindig
reference implementation,
and it uses jQuery.
So I'm gonna show you, like,
how to take something
that was written in jQuery
and do the GQuery equivalent.
So here we go with--
what it does
is over here on the left
there's, like,
a navigation bar.
And when you hover over
these li links,
it puts this, like, little
gradient background on it
and then makes it clickable,
'cause normally it's just
like an li link.
And here's the jQuery
code to do that.
My time's getting
a little bit short,
so I'm gonna have
to speed up a little bit.
It basically targets
the li elements there
in that really long selector,
and it calls a jQuery function
called hover.
Now hover's
an interesting function.
What you do is you pass
two callback functions to it--
one to call you when someone
hovers the element
and one to call you
when they leave--
un-hover the element.
And you can see what they're
doing in the callbacks
is they're saying,
"If you hover it,
"add this class called
ui-state-hover to the element.
"And if you leave--
you stop hovering,
remove that class
ui-state-hover."
So here's what the same thing
looks like in GQuery.
So we have the same
selector.
And we have
the .hover function.
And then what's that?
Oh, no, it's an anonymous
inner class.
So one of the things
you're used to
if you're using JavaScript
is that you have closures.
You can pass
little function snippets
very easily and very succinctly
into methods.
But Java doesn't have
first class functions
or high order functions.
It only has
anonymous inner classes.
So this is how you would
normally do it,
and jQuery fully supports
this programming model.
So here I'm passing
two anonymous inner functions,
like new function
and then basically one--
the first one's adding
the class ui-state-hover,
and then the second one's saying
remove class ui-state-hover.
But I thought
that this experience
would turn off some people
who are used
to the jQuery
programming model.
They don't necessarily
want to write
all those boilerplate
Java code.
You know, they're usually
sort of griping about it.
And maybe there's a way
to sort of get that feel
in Java using some tricks.
So here's what I came up with--
lazy evaluation.
So what you can do is,
is you can call this function
called lazy.
And what it returns
is a lazy version
of the GQuery object
that implements
the GQuery API.
Now the thing about
the lazy version is this,
is when you
call methods on it,
like add this class or set
this CSS property or so on,
it doesn't execute it
right away.
It just records the fact that
that's what you wanted to do.
Then at the very end
when you call end,
it actually processes
all of the things
that you queued up
and turns it into a closure
and passes it to
the requisite library function.
So in this case,
you can just say,
"lazy.addClass.end"
and then pass--
it's almost like passing
a closure in JavaScript.
And if you look at the bottom,
here's sort of the mnemonic.
lazy = function() {
and end = }
And if you count
the number of keystrokes,
it's actually more succinct
than JavaScript.
I told you I would show you
some cool tricks with Java, so.
Okay, here's another thing.
I admit this part's
actually not fully baked.
I'm sort of still
in the process of figuring out
exactly what
we're gonna do here.
But I thought about
one of the cool things
is that since we have
this information
in compile time
selector interfaces
and in other parts
of the Java type system,
wouldn't it be cool
if we could auto-generate
Javadoc-like stuff
but for the designers?
So, like, for the guys
who are editing the HTML
but not writing code, right?
So what we want to do
basically
is we want to look at--
that selector interface
has all of our
compile time selectors,
and we want to produce, like,
a human readable thing
that says, you know,
"If you want to make something
a slide bullet,
you have to basically
put a class = Slide Bullet,"
or something on it, right?
So it will sort of
document the selector
for the guys who are gonna be
applying it to the HTML.
So this is what
it would look like.
This is that selector
you saw before
with all Slide Bullets,
and it has the @selector
annotation saying,
"run div.slide li."
And then what we do
is we add two extra annotations.
One is @ the design name
to give us some more
human-readable things
instead of allSlideBullets.
And then we give it
a design sample,
which is like what a fragment
of HTML would look like
that this selector
would typically target.
And then we run
our build process on it.
We compile our JavaScript,
and what will happen is,
is we'll get some
documentation output
that might look like this.
And of course, it kind of looks
not too good right now.
This is like
a prototype implementation.
But it's like a table,
and for each design element,
like Slide Bullet,
you see what is the selector
that that thing
is looking to target,
and some Javadoc
that kind of explains, like,
Slide Bullets are li items
with a ul
that you want to appear
as animated bullet points
triggered by a space bar
or mouse click.
And then underneath it
includes the sample, which is
class = div
class = slide ul li
and so on.
The idea here
is that the programmer
would be able
to hand this document
to a guy who maybe
only knows HTML and CSS,
and that guy could know what
he has to put into the HTML
to trigger that
GQuery library code
to target it and progressively
enhance those elements.
So it's still something
that's in the process
of being designed,
but I think it has potential.
Okay.
So plugins.
I mentioned that plugins
are a really powerful mechanism
that jQuery uses.
So obviously we have to do
the same thing for GQuery.
However, the way plugins work
in jQuery
leverages sort of a powerful
facility in JavaScript,
which is prototype
modification.
So you include a plugin
in jQuery,
it modifies the methods
on the jQuery object itself
and adds new methods to it.
And we obviously
can't do that in Java.
It's a statically compiled
language.
You can't add methods
to the class at run time
or, you know,
even compile time.
I mean, you can
sub class it, but--
So how do we get around that?
So what I did is I came up
with this mechanism
of using some trickery
with Java Generics.
so all you have
to write is .as
and then you write
the name of the plugin.
So here you can see
a thing that says
.as(Effects) right?
And once you do that,
they new methods
that are in that plugin
sort of materialize
on a sub type
that comes out of that.
So you see
that the pop-up's saying
that there's a fade in
method,
a fade out method,
and so on.
So I'm gonna give you
an example
of a plugin I wrote--
not that I wrote,
that I ported,
called The jQuery
Star Rating Plugin.
So here's an HTML
Web 1.0 page.
It has some radio buttons
on the right and left here.
Sorry, on the right.
And this could be like
a rating thing for a forum.
Like maybe it says
at the end of a document,
"How would you rate this article
from one to five?"
And you have, like,
five radio buttons there.
And then you would submit
a form to the server
to submit the result
of you filling out
those radio buttons.
But we want to
progressively enhance that
so it's done on the client's
side and it looks nicer.
So I'm gonna click this button
down here that says Enhance,
and it turns it into stars.
So now I can mouse
over the stars like that.
I can click to set the rating.
The interesting thing is,
is that it's actually
reflecting
the click on the star
in the underlying HTML form.
So if you were to submit this
using a regular form submit,
the server on the back-end
that's written in PHP or Python
or Java, whatever it is,
would get that rating value
as a regular, you know,
form submit.
So the code for that
looks like this.
Oops.
GWT.
Let's see here, what's
the name of that function?
Plugin module.
Okay, so here it is
right here.
Oops, no, no.
Here it is right here.
Sorry.
This is like a callback when
you click the Enhance button.
And all it does
is this is the line of code,
one line of code.
Whoops.
Oops.
Where'd it go?
Uh, give me a second.
Okay.
Okay, this one line
of code right here--
I'll highlight it for you--
is all I had to do
to activate the plugin.
I said $input,
which is a CSS selector,
run time selector says,
"Find all the input elements
in the page,"
which all happen to be
radio buttons.
and .as(ratings)--
so that's the ratings plugin--
and then execute
the rating method,
and that's sufficient.
It executes the plugin
that goes to the page
and runs GQuery code
to progressively enhance it.
So it's really simple
to write plugins.
So if you're interested
in doing it--
and I would encourage people
who are interested
to contribute plugins to me
'cause I need help--
you only have to do
four things to implement it.
First, you write
your plugin class in Java
and you extend
the GQuery object.
Second, you implement
an interface called Plugin
that parameterized
by your class type.
Third, you have a static
initializer on your class
that invokes
GQuery.registerPlugin
and passes, like,
your class.
And then last,
you put a static variable
on your class.
Typically, you name it
the same as your class
so that people can use it
as a succinct way
to refer to the plugin.
They can say .as
and then, like, Effects
or Star Ratings or whatever.
And they can
statically import it,
so they don't
have to write like,
"com.foo.bar.starrating."
You know, they can
sort of import it
and just use
a very succinct label.
So it's being released
as open source today.
You can go to gwtquery.com
and download it.
It's still sort of Beta,
but it mostly works.
I'd encourage people
to download it, try it out,
and help me fix it up.
Contribute to the core,
write plugins.
Give me feedback.
And before I go further,
I'd like to thank--
I don't know
if he's here today--
but someone named
Manuel Carrasco.
Just, like, two weeks before
I started doing this
for the show,
submitted me, like,
a massive patch.
He did unit tests
for, like, half the functions,
he wrote documentation.
It just appeared out of nowhere
as a lifesaver.
So I'd like to thank him,
wherever he is,
for the patches.
I've integrated them
with GQuery.
And I'd encourage
more people like him
to come forward
and help us out.
And I'd encourage you
to follow my blog in the future,
timepedia.blogspot.com,
where I frequently talk
about these things.
So we're getting
to the ten-minute mark.
I have time for questions.
If you want to ask me
a question, come to the mic.
[applause]
Thank you.
man: Looks great.
Looking forward to using it.
Glad it's open source now.
Can you comment
on the other announcement
I heard, I think yesterday,
about GWT team
bringing this into GWT.
Cromwell: Yeah.
You'll have to ask Bruce
and some of the GWT team
more about this,
but they would like to.
And I think
at the current stage
it probably is a little rough
around the edges for that.
But I think, and I would
say this in general
for getting anything
into the GWT trunk,
is that you should join
the GWT contributors list.
If you've got some kind
of cool new feature
you want to add to GWT,
make a project on Google code
or put it into the incubator.
Have people use it,
test it out,
see what needs to be changed
to make it more usable
or fit more use cases.
Get it to a point where
it's more mature and reliable,
and then it probably
will make it into the trunk.
They're very open
about accepting stuff
into the GWT trunk.
There's been a lot
of contributors,
and I hope that
at some point in the future
it will be in the GWT trunk,
maybe 2.0.
Next question.
man: Hi.
Regarding the benchmark,
what versions of libraries
of Dojo, Prototype--
Cromwell: The Newest.
Prototype 1.6.
The very latest Dojo as of
whatever it was last week.
And jQuery 1.3.2.
I can check--
Actually, I have them
sitting in my IDE,
so I can tell you
what the versions are.
So let's see here.
jQuery 1.3.1.
Prototype 1.6.03.
And whatever, I think Dojo
is just called Dojo,
but maybe there's
a version string in there.
I don't know what version
this is.
It's whatever the latest
version of Dojo is.
It's the one with
the Sizzle engine in it.
man: All right, thanks.
Cromwell: By the way,
just to mention,
the SlickSpeed benchmark
that I used is an older version.
They added
more selectors to it.
So, you know, the results
might be different
if you used
the newest SlickSpeed,
which uses a lot more
varied selectors.
Next question.
man: What is the GWT using
to detect the browser?
Cromwell:
Okay, so the way GWT works
is it doesn't--
You can use either
browser sniffing
or capability detection.
You can do either one.
So two things are going on.
One is is that
there's browser sniffing
for like IE, Safari,
and so on.
And that's done by this
very small start-up script
that sniffs the browser
and then loads up
which compiled version
for which browsers.
Like, it loads up
the IE6 version if it's IE6.
That's one way of doing it.
The way I did GQuery is I did
a capability detection.
So you can write what's called
a provider in GWT,
which participates
in the start-up,
bootstrap process.
And what I do
is I check, like,
document.queerySelectorAll.
If it's there, I load up
the querySelectorAll version.
Or document.evaluate,
then I fall back to XPath.
And if neither of them
are there,
then I load up
the one that's JavaScript.
Next. Any questions?
Okay, so there's a little bit,
um, administration here.
Don't forget--
And I want to encourage you
to basically complete
the survey
and sort of evaluate
the session.
There's the URL for it,
haveasec.com/io.
So please take the time
to do that.
Thank you very much.
[applause]